[Music]
the winner of American Idol is Maddie
poppy Maddie you were up there the tears
have dried a little bit but the tears
were streaming down your face while
you're performing how do you feel right
now is this overwhelming oh man this is
this ooh I just can't even believe that
just to know that America picked me and
believed in what I was doing and I
didn't have to change myself as such I
just can't even believe it it really is
just an incredible feeling I'm voting
for you Katy Perry I think influenced
this a lot I really have to say thank
you to her too because I know that she
tweeted and she was like a really big
advocate for me actually and she really
believed in me when you know when a lot
of people were going for the more
mainstream artists and she really saw
something in me that I couldn't believe
and you and Caleb we learned tonight are
dating what had you guys talked about
what would happen if you wound up in the
final two and is this crazy we thought
well if we get to the final two all
right I guess we were just kind of
playing it by ear but you know we really
wish that this could happen and just
like this you know that it happened and
we just I'm so happy I'm so on top of
the world I can't even believe that this
is my life so it's pretty amazing we've
supported her and we've given our our
truthful criticism you know constructive
criticism is what us we're all about
personally I just gave her some feedback
right then and there when she was like
taking it all in I'm like trust your
intuition because that's what got you
here make smart choices and know that
your voice matters and speak up if you
feel uncomfortable break up if it
doesn't resonate with you and always
trust that because you're meant to be
where you are
[Music]
[Applause]